-The committee investigating the
January 6th insurrection
has subpoenaed another round of
Trump allies,
as multiple
investigations of Trump
and his inner circle intensify
and Republicans
continue their attempt to take
control of our elections.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Guys, tomorrow is a big day.
No, it's not just Thanksgiving,
it's the deadline
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
set for himself to file
his supposedly blockbuster
Supreme Court case,
proving definitively that there
was fraud in the 2020 election.
-I cannot wait to drop this
Supreme Court case
the Tuesday at 9:00 a.m.
before Thanksgiving,
and the whole world is going
to be watching all this unfold
over Thanksgiving.
-You are saying that on the
Tuesday before Thanksgiving,
which I think
is four weeks away,
you're going to drop a lawsuit.
So you can go back and have
fistfights?
The family squabbles.
Lindell, your genius.
Only you could've thought of
this.
-Steve, Steve,
I wanna say this --
-The country's going to
go back at --
your holidays
are ruined again, okay?
-And when I say before
Thanksgiving, we are bringing
the case to them down before
Thanksgiving, everybody.
Getting
all these states on board,
we've got right now
upwards of nine.
I want to get at least
25 on board.
-"Upwards of nine" already
sounds like a problematically
vague wording
for a Supreme Court case.
"And how many states are on
board, Mr. Lindell?"
"Upwards of nine."
"So 10."
"There's about 10 for sure,
that ballpark, yeah."
"Why won't you tell us the
exact number?"
"It's not important, just please
make my friend president again."
And, I'm sorry,
Steve Bannon thinks Americans
need a lawsuit
from Mike Lindell
to have a reason
to fight at Thanksgiving.
My Uncle Ron needs to drinks
and he turns into Mike Lindell.
One minute, he's telling
Aunt Debbie she's his light,
and the next minute
he's screaming,
"You pretend to be a loyal wife,
but I know about the affairs!"
And again, I know Lindell's
from Minnesota and not Chicago,
but I don't care.
Still, good news for families
trying to avoid conflict.
Lindell has failed to file
his lawsuit, as promised,
and he's blaming it on the
Republican National Committee.
Lindell accused the RNC of
calling state attorneys general
and pressuring them
not to sign the complaint.
He also said he was flying
to five different states
to get attorneys general
to sign the document.
Holiday travel is
stressful enough as it is.
Imagine being in a boarding area
with this guy
who is definitely going to
stand up when Group One
is called, no matter
what group he's sitting in.
Plus, you know, he carries
his ticket in some weird
Ziploc travel pouch.
He forgot how to open.
It's tricky because you got to
pull it while you squeeze it.
There are two things happening
on parallel tracks
right now,
in American politics.
On the one hand,
Republicans like Lindell
are still spreading the big lie
that the election was stolen,
making it easier
to overturn future results
they don't like.
And on the other hand,
several major investigations
of key Trump allies
who tried to steal
the last election
are getting more serious.
For example, the congressional
committee investigating
the January 6th insurrection
has subpoenaed
five more Trump allies,
including disgraced
right wing conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones, who always looks
like he's trying to hulk out,
even though he wasn't
exposed to gamma rays.
And Roger Stone,
the guy who famously showed
up to Trump's inauguration
looking like an 18th century
oil baron
who makes his own meth
at home.
Quick aside,
we've use that photo
so many times over the years,
I honestly
can't remember
which jokes we made about it
and which ones we haven't.
Here's a bunch anyway.
This guy looks like
Willy Wonka's mortician.
Is Quentin Tarantino
remaking "Lincoln"?
He looks like a fella
who just made his first million
in the Zeppelin business.
Dude looks like he's trying
to sneak into the Met Gala
to sell cocaine.
"Hey, Chalamet!
Chalamet.
Care to partake
in the Devil's dandruff?"
Now, you might remember that
Stone was already convicted
as part of
the Russia investigation,
but his sentence
was commuted by Trump,
and he ended up right back
in the middle of Trump's
inner circle,
helping hatch their next scheme.
-Stone was convicted
of seven felony counts
stemming from the Russia
investigation,
including obstruction
of the investigation,
lying to investigators
and witness tampering.
That then only resulted
in President Trump
commuting his sentence
in July 2020,
just in time for Stone
to help plan
the January 6th insurrection.
Stone appeared at multiple
Stop the Steal events
in the days
leading up to the attack.
-Stone is part of this
constellation
of far right
media personalities,
perhaps more than anybody else.
Roger Stone is fluent in Trump,
and he knows how to produce
slogans and commentary
that fit into his vernacular.
-What does it mean
to be "fluent in Trump"?
You only use words
with one syllable.
You talk like a cab driver
from Queens,
or you know how to stretch
a single sentence
into a rambling,
hour long monologue.
Can you imagine
one of those
French-to-English
travel dictionaries?
Except it was Trump-to-English?
Alright, let me translate.
So, Trump said, "A man came out
to me, tears in his eyes."
He said, 'Sir, you're bringing
America back, sir.
We're living in the golden age
of America, sir.
They're just like
the golden age of television.
Lucille Ball. 'I love Lucy.'
You love Lucy. We all love Lucy.
Don't we folks?
She ate all that chocolate
and got paid for it.
What a deal.
I said to my team.
'We need more chocolate eating
jobs,' and that's what we did.
We opened more
chocolate factories
under my administration
than any previous administration
in history.
Witch Hunt."
Okay. And that translates
to "I am sad inside."
So investigators are closing in
on more Trump allies,
the investigation
has already subpoenaed
former New York Police
Commissioner Bernard Kerik,
a close ally
of Rudy Giuliani,
who is part of a so-called
command center
set up by Trump cronies like
Steve Bannon ahead of the Jan.
six insurrection,
where they hatched plans
to steal the election
from Biden.
-The headquarters for some
key figures in Trump's effort
to overturn the 2020 election.
Rudy Giuliani, Steve Bannon,
former New York City Police
Commissioner Bernard Kerik
and conservative lawyer
John Eastman
holed up
in Washington's Willard Hotel.
Walking distance
from the White House
in a suite of rooms they called
"The Command Center."
-It's just fun to imagine
Rudy Giuliani
running a command center
in a hotel room.
"Let's get started.
Bernie, you split up
the free toiletries,
I call the tiny shampoo.
Steve, ordered me a Cobb salad,
but six rows of eggs.
They know how to do it."
It's also important to remember
these people only hang out
with each other
because there is no one else
who will hang out with them.
If Bernie Kerik
had other options,
do you think he would still roll
with Rudy Giuliani,
who publicly implied
a few months ago
that they all partied
with disgraced
royal Prince Andrew.
-I told this to the Queen of
England. She said
[As Queen Elizabeth] "You did,
you did a wonderful job
on September 11,
And therefore I'm making you
an honorary knight
commander of the royal,
something or other.
[ Normal voice ]
I turned down a knighthood
because if you took
a knighthood,
you had to lose
your citizenship.
I know Prince Andrew
is very questionable now.
I never went out with him.
Never, never,
never had a drink with him.
Never was with a woman or a
young girl with him ever, ever.
One time I met him
in my office,
and one time when we had the
party right party, right Bernie,
you were there.
You weren't there? Oh [bleep]
"You weren't there?
Oh, now I remember, Bernie.
You said if anyone ever asked,
I wasn't here.
And then you said,
wink wink."
Oh, just say what you will
about my impressions,
but they're way better
than Rudy's.
I mean, is that is that what he
thinks the queen sounds like?
Who does he think played her in
"The Crown," Al Pacino?
[ As Pacino ] "Whoa, nothing
makes me smile like a Corgi
running across
a well-manicured lawn.
Low to the ground
and fast like a rocket ship.
Let's get a round of crumpets.
Out here.
It is always crumpet o'clock.
At Buckingham Palace.
And of course,
Rudy is already facing
his own criminal investigation
for trying to cheat
in the 2020 election
before the results came in.
Investigators are focusing
on his attempts to dig up dirt
on Joe Biden in Ukraine.
And as you might recall,
his home and office
were raided by the feds
earlier this year.
Last night, he was on Newsmax
and claimed
that only Trump cronies
are targeted by the feds.
-[ British accent ]
I have to get your reaction
to the breaking news.
These five new subpoenas
from the January 6th
committee of Nancy Pelosi.
The idea that we've had
Roger Stone subpoenaed
Alex Jones,
three other individuals
add to that Mark Meadows
and Steve Bannon.
Are we seeing the collapse
of of the rule of law
at the highest levels
in the United States, Mr. Mayor?
-Yeah, Sebastian, we watched
that all through
the Trump presidency.
I mean, the Democrats handled
themselves like fascists.
They -- there were
no constitutional rules.
Why is it that the only lawyers
whose law offices
get broken into
are Donald Trump's lawyers?
Remember, they went and got
my iCloud account.
I'm a lawyer.
-Alright, but not really.
I mean, your law license
was suspended
and you lost every case
you brought after the election.
The only thing
you succeeded at doing
was drumming up publicity
for a landscaping company.
I mean, it looks like
he's shooting
a local commercial for them,
[As Giuliani]
Come on down to Four Seasons
Total Landscaping,
our prices are so crazy you'll
be screaming, "Why God?"
"Why?"
[ Normal voice ] But hey, at
least he's not the kind of guy
who puts his thumb
on the front-facing camera.
More importantly,
let's go back to this
penetrating question.
-Why is it that the only lawyers
law offices get broken into
are Donald Trump's lawyers?
-Yeah, why is it such a mystery?
It's like asking
why the only rats
who go viral are pizza rats.
What about all the other
everyday working class rats?
When is their time in the sun?
The Command Center,
the lawsuits,
the Ukrainian scheme?
All of it was part
of the Trump team's
attempt to cheat in
or steal the election.
And as part of that effort,
they produced memo after memo
laying out a detailed plan
for Vice President Mike Pence
to reject
the Electoral College count.
There were a bunch of memos
from several Trump lackeys.
In fact, former Trump national
security adviser Michael Flynn
even tried to get
the Pentagon involved
in their attempted coup.
It wasn't just an impulse,
or Trump randomly lashing out,
they had a detailed plan.
and a Command Center
to pull it off.
And believe me,
I'm as shocked as you are
that these misshapen
potato chips had a plan.
It's much easier
to think of them
as a bunch of easily
distracted doofuses
who get caught trying to steal
a pen from a bank
without realizing
it's chained to the desk.
But they did have a plan
and they came close
to pulling it off,
which means they're almost
certainly going to try it again.
Except this time
they're trying to do it
by changing the laws
to make it easier,
and they have
Republican officials in states
across the country helping them.
They've already started
passing new voting laws
in at least 17 states,
and now they've landed on their
next target, Wisconsin.
-In a stunning new piece of
reporting in The New York Times,
Ron Johnson and other
Republicans in Wisconsin
have now launched
an all out assault
on their state's
election system
to ensure Republicans have full
control over its voting process.
From that reporting
"the Republican effort broader
and more forceful
than that in any other state,
where allies of former
President Donald J. Trump
are trying to overhaul
elections,
takes direct aim
at the bipartisan Wisconsin
Elections Commission."
Last month, a report ordered
by Republican state legislators
and performed
by Wisconsin's nonpartisan
Legislative Audit Bureau,
found, big surprise here
no widespread fraud
in the 2020 election.
But the report did make
dozens of recommendations
for the Election Commission,
and Republicans pounced.
-Think about how insane that is.
They conducted an audit
that found
no evidence of fraud
but made a bunch
of recommendations anyway.
It's like if you went
to the doctor
for a physical
and he said,
"Alright, everything
looks perfect.
We'll take the leg off
on Monday.
Not sure how many bones
are in there,
but it's got to be -"
-Upwards of nine.
[ Laughter ]
-Dah, callback!
This is the single
greatest existential threat
to our democracy right now,
and it's hanging over
every aspect of our politics,
one party wants
to take control
so they can never
lose power again.
From Steve Bannon to
Roger Stone to Rudy Giuliani,
it seems like everyone
around Trump
was involved
in the attempted coup.
And now that they're
all getting subpoenaed,
they're saying --
-Oh, [bleep].
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDs, cancer,
and other serious illnesses.
And they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.